welcome back so let's continue where we
left off so we had this this uh this
intuition that i must have something to
do with these sign changes right the
pattern of the sign changes of i are
very similar to the pattern of the sign
changes in the maclaurin representation
of cosine of x plus sine of x and then
we also saw that the i's whether they're
positive eyes or negative i's
correspond to the sine terms
so let's do a little experiment and it's
not an experiment because i know where
this leads to but but it could have been
an experiment
what is e to the ix
e
to the i
x
well raising anything to the i power
really isn't defined i mean when i
itself was created by a definition we
said i squared is equal to negative 1 by
definition
so i is a bit of a definition so if we
haven't defined what something to the i
the power is yet
we really don't we really don't
know what to do with it
but let's just say for the sake of you
know that we can treat i like just like
any other number
and we do know what happens
with i when you put into a polynomial
that's one thing we do know we can in
fact that's one of the reasons why i was
defined in the first place was so that
people could take roots of all
polynomials even ones that didn't have
real roots
so what happens if we take edix well i
don't know what that is but we know we
could put that into the maclaurin
representation of e to the x and
actually since you're taking my leap of
faith that that is equal to e of x and
all of its derivatives are equal to e e
to the x's derivatives at x equals zero
it's not that hard to imagine and
actually you could plot the graph of
this and you'll see that they're they're
identical but anyway so if we take the
maclaurin representation of this
everywhere where we see an x we just
replace it with an i x right
so that will be
plus
i
x
plus
so what's
well let me let me just write it plus
i squared
x squared over 2 factorial
that whoops i squared x squared
plus
i to the third
x to the third
over three factorial
plus
i to the fourth
x to the fourth
over four factorial
plus i to the fifth
x to the fifth over five factorial i
don't have to keep going plus and it
just keeps going right so what happens
when you simplify that when you
so that equals
one
plus i
x what's i squared that's negative 1
right
minus
x squared
over 2 factorial
and what's i to the third that's minus i
so it's minus i
x to the third
over three
factorial
plus i to the fourth so it's out of the
four that's just one again so we get
plus
x to the fourth
over four factorial
and then we have what's i to the fifth
plus i
times x to the fifth
over five factorial right it just keeps
going
we have something interesting here now
all of a sudden we have something
extremely similar to this
except for only one difference
right compare that to e to the ix
compare that to e to the eighth and the
dots on my eyes always get merged
compare these two things that i'm
circling
what's the difference
let's see the 1 1 well here i have an x
i have an i x here the minus x squared
over two factors so
these terms are the same
then on the x to the third the signs are
right but have an i
and then
x to the fourth or four factorial that's
identical but then on x to the fifth
i have an i
so the only difference between this and
this
is on the terms that involve sine of x
right
so what are the terms that involve sine
of x it's
this term
corresponds to that term right
corresponds to that term right these are
the terms that correspond to sine of x
in this representation
that term corresponds to that term and
the only difference is so this has all
of the terms that the sine of x would
have but they all have a
an i in front of them right even the
sign is right right this is negative
that's negative but this just has an i
in front of it
so it turns out that you could you could
rewrite this right you could rewrite
this representation well it doesn't turn
out it's pretty obvious you could be
right let me let me
clear this just so we get a
so we could actually rewrite that e to
the ix
e to the
ix
and we could write it
we could separate out the kind of the i
the imaginary terms and we could
separate out the real terms what were
the real terms well the real terms were
minus
x squared
over 2 factorial
plus
x to the 4th
over four factorial
minus
x to the sixth over six factorial and it
just kept going to infinity right those
were the real terms
and that will and then and that's two
infinity dot dot dot
now this pen tool is doesn't look it
looks like minus signs i don't want to
do that edit undo edit undo
edit undo
edit
oh i can't undo it anyway so this is
just dot dot dot right you could say
plus dot dot dot so those are the real
those are the the real terms essentially
and then the imaginary terms it was
plus
well all of these terms are going to
have i on them right so let me just to
take the i out so plus
i
times and we figured out that those
terms were x and they were the terms at
minus well i don't want to give it away
too fast x the third over three
factorial
plus
x to the fifth
over five factorial
minus
x to the seventh over seven factorial
and it just kept going on on and on to
infinity right
well isn't this the maclaurin
representation of cosine of x
and similarly
isn't this the maclaurin representation
of sine of x
well yeah sure and i mean it you
probably realize in the previous screen
where i showed that all of the imaginary
terms correspond to the sine of x terms
and all the real ones likewise were the
cosine of x when we said that when we
compared it to sine of x plus cosine of
x
so if you believe me that the maclaurin
representation of e to the x
is equal to e to the x and the maclaurin
representation of cosine and sine of x
are equal to those functions then all of
a sudden
we come up with this bizarre and amazing
and mystical
idea that e
to the i
x
is equal to
cosine of x
plus i
times the sine of x and this is called
euler's formula
and actually e stands for euler that's
where it comes from
euler starts with an e e u l e r
but this is amazing
not only have we found a relationship
between this bizarre mystical magical
number e
and these you know these trigonometric
functions that we defined as the ratio
of the sides of right triangles but now
we're involving this other mystical
magical number that we invented just so
that all of our all of our polynomials
would have some root whether or not
they're real or not we have this number
i all of a sudden showing up
this by itself is amazing but now we
could take it one step further and this
should blow your mind if it doesn't then
you are you have no emotion i i will
just judge you
so if if we take this and i mean
essentially we're
we're taking it that that when you take
something to the i power that you can
just substitute into a small chlorine
representation but anyway i won't go
into the details but i think you can say
that this is this is a pretty reasonable
uh proposition but what happens if we
take something
to the pi power where if e to the i pi
power well
before we didn't have any way of saying
well what does that mean taking
something i pi power but now we do
because we're saying that these two
sides of this are equal to each other so
what happens
e let me do this in a bold color because
it deserves to be bold e to the i
pi
is equal to well where x is pi is equal
to cosine
of pi
plus i sine of pi
well what's cosine of pi this is equal
to negative one
and sine of pi well that's just equal to
zero
and we get e to the i pi
is equal to
negative one
this is amazing or you could also write
e to the i
pi
plus one
is equal to zero
once again amazing either of these
should make you question your take on
reality because we have the number pi
which is the ratio of a circumference of
a circle to its diameter we have the
number e that comes from that comes from
a
continuous compound interest and then we
have the number i which is you know kind
you can say the square root of negative
one or it squared is negative one and
they all come together this formula
right here it involves all the
fundamental numbers in mathematics but
they come from completely different
directions completely different
directions and although we can prove
this and we can say this is true i'll
tell you no one no one probably in the
history of mankind fully understands why
this is this is just a glimpse on some
type of order in the universe